ladies and gentlemen  please welcome the newlyweds mr and mrs  simon doyle  you must meet archul puero he's the  greatest detective alive  i suspect you invited me for reasons  other than the fun  when you have money no one is ever  really your friend  the crime is murder  the murderer  is one of you  it was methodically planned  did you see or hear anything  someone else is dead what did you do  last night you accused me of murder  he accuses everyone of murder it is a  problem i admit  i want you to find who did this  there are so many conflicting hates and  jealousies  lock the doors  the murderer is here and we'll stay here  death on the nile with the pg-13  exclusively in theaters february 11.